what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we're here to watch Visions episode four
five and six if you wanna watch one two and three
that is on a separate video of course joined by
Star Wars expert Michael Tessler followed him on
social media use the force to leave a like you
know what to do and as always full length scratch
and watch how long's reducing up with your own
copy available for a super sexy rejects that are
a patreon hey thank you all who have joined us so
far but guys our Star Wars Visions reactions are
sponsored by a sponsor that I freaking love get
out of the way for a little bit Michael thank you
again to me underneath for sponsoring this video
guys I'm in a onesie I've never owned a onesie
and my epidermis has never felt more comfortable
nay I need a better word than comfortable I
feel as snug as a bug in a rug I obviously
love their clothing I went to the Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 premiere and I even wore the
Rocket Raccoon lounge pants that people would not
stop talking about it easily the most comfortable
one there at the event now I am entering further
into the galaxy far far away you might say with
this limited edition print of AKA baby Yoda is the
child himself grogu has traveled across the Galaxy
and into our hearts and now you can meditate
with him and galactically soft undies socks
bralettes loungewear and more available in sizes
extra small to 4XL like I said the new Star Wars
Prince is limited so grab this bounty now before
it's all gone they also gave me their shorts which
again is so soft and perfect fitting too even
my wife loves to wear them speaking of my wife
I even got this bralette for her too I said take
it off I'm showing it in the video Woman she'd
love seeing me in this underwear my Jedi Mind
Tricks to keep her attracted to me don't work
but this underwear is doing at the job wearing
it right now I've never been more relaxed on
camera sitting has just generally never felt so
soothing but yes rejection the hype is real do
not impressed with me on these your first pair is
on the house Seth is a promise so to get 25 off
your first order and free standard shipping go to
mionys.com rejects once again that is mionys.com
Rejects and May the force be with you always I
hope they partner up with us again because yes
this is your final call whoa Wallace and
grommet City Light Academy it's our annual
celebration of our pilot trainees
and their families believe it or not
an actual Star Wars character this is canon
that's racist Craig
also Harris undul still racist
R2 oh look at that Astra Mac
I am your mother boiling
a slinky the dog this is red leader
oh that's the planet they're
from I made lunch right
Harris and Doula is on the poster
her name's Annie thoroughly
you forgot your lunch City flight
Academy's annual race day be sure
to check out the official wedge themed
products I love this idea that wedge
Milwaukee
flying porta potty I hate you space tug actually
that's it someone has to do the basic maintenance
they have that exact balloon
at Disney World do they yeah
oh my that's inappropriate
oh it's their home
oh mother
oh no silly Billy can you come back later
clean up will be after the race oh Annie
can you get your Porta-Potty off the starting
line thank you eh don't worry we're leaving
pissed off the wrong Mom let's get
strapped in why are we strapping in we
aren't just moving the ship aren't
we go nope always wear a seat belts
family race is on
please
oh no
one in these days oh you can't say that junk is
embarrassing said one barely functioning
is embarrassing you are embarrassing no
is that how you really feel yeah
Julian mommy's waiting do it oh
be anytime I play Battlefront 2. is
that one activate the stabilizers
get the controls I can't find this
her mom falls out dies it's all her fault
yeah Voice work is so consistent
ah yes
who needs parents when you can win the race
this is really cute hold on red leader he's about
to get bumpy and yet another win for the van repos
oh this junkyard racing Vibe that's so much fun
place is last place no
extraordinary
Holy balls
watch them be last we have
Ubuntu Eve
I've learned a lot from you exactly I should
have told you about the race even if you can be a
little bit embarrassing of course I'm embarrassing
I am your mother I am your mother I'm your father
ah well that was cute yeah that was a nice uh
a nice break from the serious stuff I know she
learned to use the force at the end that's
what happened that's what that's how these
all go right here they all you learn to use the
forks yeah no that was great uh just another cute
mother-daughter story filled with a bunch of
cute little Easter eggs throughout uh I'm not
my admittedly not my favorite of the four we've
seen so far this was my favorite I made it yeah
but it was really fun and I think at the end of
the day that's the whole point the whole point is
to have the variety and just have something that
is just super adorable here like they're so family
friendly and I think I think the other prior three
are not like super family friendly uh they're
they're so much more mature in the way they're
executed but to have that kind of break a little
bit of that like British wit to it uh I thought
was awesome and I mean the animation still is
like Vivid and colorful as you'd want I've never
seen Wallace and Gromit I've seen chicken I saw
a chicken run when I was like my movie stresses
man seven so I don't remember chicken run at all
um that'd be fun I actually react to that on
this channel I've seen it before it might be
fun to react to that uh but yeah I thought that
was still a really adorable piece that they had
right there yeah a little hey Greg yeah I want
to watch the next one okay he's just trying to
shorten and sort of the talk are you I want
to watch the next one all right we'll watch
the next one I want to hear about you never run
there were Easter eggs Michael come on I did so
good with the Easter eggs the Easter eggs I was
I was bored I was Harrison Doula I saw them all
I got them all yeah you did yeah sneaky guy oh
his next one's long let's see what's going on
that's so pretty is that dust or water
looks like water yeah yes can confirm
that's gorgeous yeah right
that's whence every time
read better
foreign
thank you
why are the seventh Envision so cool
yikes
where's this Weaponry I think it's
a biological part of them like a
Tails
this guy's like all for one for my hero
Academia I like that he branded him oh
yeah
I don't think tell us the one for the job
I was gonna say I feel like he's
going through some things right now
honey all their paths at the dark side so
anger usually stems from Fear hello there
that's humiliated
nowhere
this guy looks just like Hunter from Owl House
and your fans will know what I'm talking about
oh damn this mission was meant
for him to confront this guy
oh I'm ready to make you a
Sith I'll start by killing you
God I love this POV
no
ship looks like kylo's
ah yes on the way to bang sing say foreign
too much anger bud
for real we've been the palm
of the hand lifting you up
foreign
what's the plan here
ah cool America
all right
oh cool
fiber crystals oh that's really cool
uh what
they both found balance yeah same Christmas
you need the balance she's gonna help me
she represents the balance
oh oh I just got chilled that's cool
to face your Darkness
off off with your head is that
Jonathan majors in the statue
the dance with Tat's ass music
jet pack jet pack parachute parachute
no oh it's time for him um
all right
all right we got ourselves the anime
episode that was gorgeous it was great
I love the tone of it overall as well
um Michael why don't you talk while I fix this
little thing on screen really fast no I thought
it was uh I mean it's just like a friendly
reminder of Star Wars s Universe fits so
well into the anime genre anime particularly for
some of the more ancient stories it really really
works and I'm surprised they don't just make a
show about something from a long time ago that
doesn't necessarily affect the rest of Canon
this is beautiful I mean I think uh I will say
I'm just a little tired of like the balance yeah
yeah it's becoming a little bit too reoccurring
here especially envisions like I'm like did you
guys consult with each other about the repetition
of some of the stories I don't think that they
did yeah I like the idea of like they get the
free reign but at the same time it is like it's
becoming a little repetitive yeah I guess I just
wish dig a little bit deeper like something
a little bit different I mean the difference
comes in the fact that the animation itself is
so much of a character and that character really
does shine through here and I I love anime so
for me I'm like this was a really enjoyable
piece of Star Wars entertainment that is like
kind of like a lot of anime villains behave a
kind of cold-hearted emptiness in the way they
do delivery and sense of like that that over
confidence in it and then a really aggressive
protagonist who's dealing with anger there's
a lot of like good anime tropes in here and also
just Sith troops yeah Sith tropes but like really
captured in the language of a lot of how anime I
don't want to make it sound like all anime is the
same it's just like there are some very familiar
anime high quality here I might be super wrong uh
but I got like a lot of like Korean influence
from from this one uh like I might be just the
I I was just kind of the the vibe that I I got
where it felt a very let's say very Divergent
but it felt a bit Divergent from like traditional
Japanese anime but again don't quote me on that
uh I'm not an expert I mean it's stuff like this
when they take in when they do the anime style
their minds of things like ghosts in the Shell
or like Cowboy Bebop uh like or see it steps past
um Space Opera and starts feeling like genuine
sci-fi you know and I thought that this really
that's really captured that and like yeah the the
kinship of these two I like the wrap around that
they have with that girl I think there's just
so much familiarity but it was still a really
enjoyable piece with some really Vivid expressive
animation again that's kind of like the the main
selling point of Visions is the uniqueness in
in the the actual physical vision of what we
were watching I think they did a great job of
capturing them to see like it all done in like
a Japanese culture does feel like a cool like all
Universe yeah can we watch another one please yeah
yeah well Ross still another really
great one man that was still uh super fun
okay okay I see you
have you said Stormtrooper fat
Stormtrooper heavy sets Stormtrooper
spy dancer we missed
you is this what I think it is
yeah it's the form of it
it's a circus what were you thinking Craig
sits in the house you won't miss A Beat from
here keep your eyes open you guys okay this
is really really pretty ah yes welcome
to Le space Moulin Rouge let me do more
you're not ready yet don't interfere with
the show the show is pointless how can you
still be able to serve these Invaders it
is don't start we talked about it not the
two different colored eyes I love the French
Resistance Vibes here in World War II yeah hey
hey it's the French Resistance I'm super here
for this do these ones even work don't frighten
remember I'll be able to follow every one
of their dirty Imperial steps on my monitor
I just need to fix our way out that's all do
you really think we have a way out John yes
yes oh my God they're just gonna blow up
everything those years helping the rebellion
and for what oh come on what we do here will
change the tides but the whole galaxy you sure
I have to go should really put that away
wow
oh I'm gonna kill them all
facial hair that's not regulation
oh wow the one responsible for her family's death
worse
uh uh answer baby
oh that is messed up
it's all part of the show folks are you okay
take everyone and leave they thought it was
now look out for John you stay with him
this is now too personal she's about to
go on glorious bastards on this guy
that is on the way with the others
take them up at the but the egg is going
on Louie I have one last thing to do here
oh my God but this is the only way I can be free
to call Jordan good job Craig
that you named a Droid right yeah
in territory looks like Patrick Stewart
oh [__] at the greatest dance of her
life Katniss Everdeen the girl on fire
a Droid oh no she stopped herself
you Rebel scum no it's not him
should have just committed
wow oh
holy crap using silks to take down the empire
nice
oh girls get it done
whoa what why are you afraid to kill this one guy
no no it's her son oh is it
you like the eye patch covers
the other eye you're right
you're right good attention to detail Mikhail
how old is she well if it happened
at the beginning it's like a 20 30
year period who are you from me I need answers
oh my God take that off
damn she good you go Miss Marvel
feels gory
about time man 20 years ago the Empire
raided all Village took my son what's
that to do with me he would be your age
why do you hide your true nature ah oh wow
oh
it's okay oh my god oh yes it's like Neo
and Morpheus some very strong Frenchman
hope
he looks just like me did he remove his
eye you think yeah I probably did that
to just strip him of any identity to that
culture because I removed his little horns
wow that was a great one yeah good I love that
one a lot of I feel like with visions a lot of
the time the main takeaway is the animation and
like this some of these disorders have been really
good but most of the time it's you know you're
mainly it's like animation's amazing yeah and
for me I stopped thinking about the animation
and I was just so hooked into the story uh and
this is the first one out of the six that we've
seen so far though where I was so pulled into
the story and it was so refreshing and different
and haven't seen something like this in Star Wars
didn't have anything to do with the Jedi which
like I mean I love the Jedi don't get me wrong
point we're like all right okay yeah I gotta get
it light him dork no it was a beautiful uh just
like a friendly reminder that like you know French
still know it's uh when it comes to animation uh I
is like a big history nerd and also I feel like
Star Wars pulls so much of its inspiration from
World War II no I loved no no no Rhymes kids uh I
loved the like touching on the French Resistance
and using something that is so kind of uniquely
French to tell that story yeah um and in so many
ways like that story has happened so many times
in real history and I don't know there's something
really like that the moment of the hug just like
ah did something like uh like that's all it took
in order for him to entirely change the trajectory
of his life and I think that's a beautiful notion
yeah I was saying hug me Greg no I'm not her
father Michael I am not your father get away
from me Mom Mommy yeah no I appreciate all the
things in riffing on the historical context
where you do feel like Nazi soldiers are walking
to like uh oh let's go to his entertainment bar
with these like attractive women and who do a
show and stuff let's drink and have a good time
um but I also loved like some of my favorite
World War II stories are like I definitely
don't know anywhere near as much as you but the
ones I am often test I mean but it if it were I
would lose and I want you to know that you win
here uh and that's what America's all about so
uh one of my favorite stories that my favorite
kinds of stories are the ones where or is like
um the revolutionists are working undercover
uh you know like they're in high they're
they will be like at the bars they'll be at the
pubs you know and they can sometimes be seductive
but they're like those they're those are some
like real life Heroes who pull that [__] off
and I think some of those are the coolest stories
to see that implemented here is neat but then you
had to have that Mother Sun angle which I feel
like should have been way more predictable for
me I totally missed it you got it I thought it was
great I thought that was it was just so different
than something we've seen in this world and it's
something that I think is so personal and Primal
for anyone that they can relate to something I
don't know for late but we can all attach onto or
empathize in some way because we all have parents
and whatnot so uh yeah I thought that was a really
strong one where I I stopped thinking I don't know
it was it was true though the Visions you usually
are like oh the animation and then for me I'm like
I could not even tell you what the animation style
is yeah now that I'm thinking about it but the
story is going to stick with me for a long time
yeah that's powerful um yeah because he doesn't
even end in a way where you're like it could go
either way where he he could not believe her or he
could believe her and I like that it doesn't end
in a definitive way that's open to interpretation
of how the path that might go down you know but
it ends on a hopeful note yeah and it's all about
Hope Greg it's what Star Wars is all about Hope
and people learning about the force and light
and dark that's what I did that's what it is
um but yeah that maybe not on an animation
level is my favorite one but from the story
levels this is this is when I feel like I truly
will not forget out of out of all the Star Wars
ones oh I think the best way to gauge a story
like this is if you took the Star Wars out of
it would it still be a good story and it is
and this one absolutely I mean I could just
very easily reimagine this as like a Noir French
film uh during World War II and it would be just
as impactful to be like oh crap just a little
kid that was stolen from the village in also
Lorraine uh yeah yeah that's cool that was really
cool I was really really impressed with that one
I was really impressed with that one um yeah I
love that one what did you guys think what was
it what was your favorite their opinion I love
their opinion screw everyone's opinions are that
are not ours we don't even know what you think
but YouTube does tell us what you think yeah for
algorithm purposes algorithm engagement and [__]
yeah I think I don't care I don't give a [__]
Greg hates French people especially the French no
this is just like I love like I know their culture
is not like at the Pinnacle that it once was but
every once in a while I'm like oh yeah that's why
that's why they were the ones
that like made our industry
the Jews did you know it's interesting you say
that let's cut let's get in this video okay